Україна наполягає на тому, щоб нову угоду про транзит російського газу
уклали відповідно до європейських правил.
Про так званий план "А" розповіла в Брюсселі
заступниця міністра закордонних справ Олена Зеркаль.
Зеркаль відзначила, що Україна розробила цей план за сприяння Сполучених Штатів.
Як саме він працюватиме, поки незрозуміло.
Західні експерти вважають, що подібні заяви не сприяють вирішенню конфлікту.
Якщо з 1 січня 2020 року транзит російського газу
через українську газотранспортну систему повністю припиниться,
то жодна угода не допоможе.
Тоді Україна не отримає газу ані з Заходу, ані зі Сходу.
Проблема в тому, що в такому разі в Європі буде дефіцит газу.
Зараз Україна отримує газ із Західної Європи,
але взагалі-то це російський газ, який закачується в Німеччину,
а потім йде назад в Україну.
Київ не зможе висувати жодних вимог, він зможе лише спробувати
купити газ, але тоді він буде дуже дорого коштувати
або його просто не буде.
На мій погляд, проблему драматизують замість того, щоб сісти за стіл переговорів.
Після того, як у січні тристоронні перемови між ЄС, Україною та Росією
про транзит газу ні до чого не призвели,
новий раунд перемовин відклали до травня,
коли в Україні виберуть нового президента.
Очікування сторін щодо нового договору дуже різняться.
В Брюсселі наполягають на довгостроковій угоді.
Євросоюз також хоче, щоб Росія прокачувала через територію України
мінімум 60 мільярдів кубометрів газу на рік.
У Москві з цим не згодні, адже коли добудують "Північний потік-2",
"Газпрому" більше не потрібні будуть такі обсяги в українській газотранспортній системі.
У "Нафтогазі" вважають, що не таке й важливе питання про те,
який мінімальний обсяг газу буде прокачуватися через ГТС.
Головне - щоб отриманого доходу вистачало на покриття витрат оператора.
Щоби підтримати українську ГТС, усі потужності, які зараз є наявні,
наявні приблизно для транзиту,
це 140 мільярдів кубічних метрів потужності.
Для цього, щоб покрити всі витрати оператора, включно з вартістю капіталу
оператора,  потрібно 3 млрд доларів приблизно.
Тобто відповідно Україна каже, що Україні потрібно
отримувати від транзиту дохід приблизно
на рівні 3 млрд доларів, а
а вже в залежності від того, який буде обсяг,
буде просто вищим або нижчим тариф транзиту.
Раніше голова "Нафтогазу" Андрій Коболєв висловлював занепокоєння,
що через "Північний потік-2" і "Турецький потік"
на газотранспортну систему України не буде попиту.
За його словами, Київ лишиться фактору стримування проти російської агресії.
Однак західні експерти вважають, що в проблемах з енергетичним сектором
є й провина України. Реформи в цій галузі давно назріли.
В Україні давно знають про цю проблему.
Вже 10 років Європа закликає провести реформи,
але цього не відбувається. Часу на це було достатньо.
Київ повинен нарешті щось зробити.
Потрібно вдатися до дій щодо заощадження енергії,
а також переходити від викопних енергоресурсів до відновлювальних.
Про такі реформи йдеться.
У Берліні продовжують наполягати на доцільності будівництва "Північного потоку-2",
однак і канцлерка Анґела Меркель, і міністр економіки Петер Альтмаєр
не раз підкреслювали, що головна умова запуску нової магістралі -
це збереження транзиту газу через територією України.